ça durcit ce qui est mon préféré
comment jouer à Wolverine il est pour moi le
personnage de bande dessinée le plus badass là-
bas bien cool que moi attend plus dur que
moi donc je peux en quelque sorte avoir une grande
réalisation de souhaits en jouant en fait je devrais
te dire mon fils  est sur le point d'avoir 13 ans tout
récemment m'a dit je suppose que je
pensais que tu étais vraiment comme Wolverine mais
tu n'es en fait pas ça donc c'est
vraiment amusant de jouer le gars le plus dur dans
la cour
combien d'entraînement se passe dans le Wolverine
la réponse simple  c'est beaucoup, je m'entraîne
essentiellement trois heures par jour deux heures
le matin, puis partout où je peux
pendant la journée, je rentre une heure de plus mais
je vais être honnête avec vous, la chose la plus
importante à propos de l'entraînement est de
manger en fait 70  % de votre apparence
est la façon dont vous mangez seulement 30% est la formation,
donc c'est probablement dans la plus vitale
une grande question des facteurs japonais de
manière massive Je ne sais pas si vous êtes un fan
de la saga de bandes dessinées le
saga samurai mais je connais beaucoup de fans j'étais  un
grand fan de celui-ci, le film se déroule au Japon,
nous avons tourné au Japon, il semble vraiment
différent, son apparence est différente,
l'atmosphère est très différente de
tout autre film x-men et à travers
Wolverine, vous entrez dans ce monde, il est
vraiment un  pêcher hors de l'eau
et je pense que le public le ressentira
aussi, c'est un monde mystérieux et fascinant très énigmatique,
mais je pense que ce que j'aime dans ce
film Wolverine et pourquoi il s'appelle The
Wolverine not ordering - est-ce une période
complètement différente non seulement que
Je pense que vous obtenez le regard définitif sur
le personnage et pour de nombreux films,
nous nous concentrons sur son manque de mémoire et
il est dans ce film, nous nous concentrons vraiment
sur son immortalité et les implications
de cela et ce que l'avenir signifie pour
quelqu'un comme Warren, je pense  les fans
trouveront vraiment un endroit rafraîchissant et
différent et très cool
aimerais-je vivre aussi longtemps que la warfarine
ouais absolument je ne connais pas beaucoup de gens
qui ne vous dérangeraient pas si j'étais de la warfarine
je pr  avoir sûrement des doutes,
c'est quelqu'un avec beaucoup de regret et de
douleur et la vie n'est pas facile pour lui et en
fait l'une des grandes choses à propos de
ce film est que vous voyez les implications
d'être presque immortel et est-ce une
bonne chose de vivre une longue vie  si vous
vivez avec beaucoup de regrets douloureux ou est-
ce un bien, c'est vraiment là que nous trouvons de l'
eau au début du film et
je veux en dire beaucoup,
je pense que la chose que j'aimais à propos de ce
Wolverine c'était vraiment un tout nouveau casting
évidemment, le film se déroule au Japon
et nous avons des acteurs japonais incroyables
, je n'oublierai jamais que nous tournions
une scène et nous avions 200 figurants et à la
fin de la journée, le héros qui est dans les films a
fait environ 80 films japonais
qu'ils n'étaient pas  impressionné de me voir,
ils tombaient littéralement sur eux-mêmes
pour voir ici et le fait qu'ils soient dans un
film avec lui, nous avons certains des
plus grands acteurs japonais, nous avons également de
tout nouveaux acteurs et je pense que pour le
public, ça va être excitant
t  voici les nouveaux mutants que je ne veux
pas trop en dire, mais à tous points de vue, ce
film va me sembler frais en tant
qu'acteur, il était complètement frais et
excitant
pour moi, ce qui me passionne le plus
pour vous, c'est  une partie de l'
action que nous avons vraiment décidée pour ce film
parce que nous avions cette incroyable nouvelle
toile du Japon,
nous avions des samouraïs, nous avions une toute nouvelle
palette avec laquelle nous pouvions donner
et faire de l'action fraîche et
excitante qui n'avait jamais été vue auparavant et  Je
vais juste dire deux mots train à grande vitesse
est-il difficile d'éteindre Wolverine Je l'
utilise occasionnellement vous savez que vous voulez obtenir des
réservations de restaurants vous voulez
vous asseoir dans le métro il y a des endroits
où cela est utile mais en fait
compagnon c'est  ça fait 12 ans que je
le joue et je peux l'allumer et l'
éteindre assez rapidement,
heureusement, je ne sais pas si je serais le
bienvenu à la maison si je me contentais de le mettre à l'échelle
et de l'appeler rumba
le film est  appelé le Wolverine et
y a-t-il de la pression sur moi  supposons qu'il y ait de la
pression, je ressens de la pression sur chaque film,
mais le bon type de pression, je suppose,
dans une analogie sportive à la fin du
jeu, deux personnes veulent que la balle lance le
crochet, mais elles le font et donc de cette façon, c'est
bien mais c'est toujours  un effort d'équipe et
dans ce film, il y a tellement d'autres
grands personnages et grands acteurs et
Jim Mangal est un réalisateur fantastique qui vient de faire en
sorte que cette pression soit complètement
gérable et les films appelés le
Wolverine ce que j'aime à ce sujet, je pense
plus que jamais avant que vous n'obteniez  un
regard définitif sur ce personnage et
ce qui fait de lui ce qu'il est et
je le joue depuis 12 ans maintenant,
donc j'attendais vraiment avec impatience leur
japonais plutôt que
James Mangold est un grand ami à moi, nous
avons fait un film ensemble appelé Kate  et
Léopold qui ne pourrait probablement pas être plus
opposé à cela, mais c'est un
réalisateur incroyable, il a une grande vision,
il a une grande ambition et il a fait
beaucoup de grands films, alors quand quelqu'un comme
James Mangold signe  va au
Wolverine vous savez que vous n'obtiendrez pas seulement
non c'est un autre Wolverine vous savez
que vous allez obtenir quelque chose de définitif
vous savez que vous allez obtenir quelque chose de
frais et vous allez obtenir quelque chose
qui vaut vraiment votre temps  pour moi, je l'ai
adoré tous les jours, c'était le plus amusant
que j'ai eu et j'espère que vous avez apprécié le
résultat autant que j'aime faire la
recherche de scoops sur Days of
Future passé bien
les côtelettes de mouton toujours là je ne
pense pas que je  Je vous donne de vrais scoops si
je vous dis que presque tous les vieux
x-men sont de retour et quand je dis les vieux
x-men, je veux dire des x-men des films
et des x-men de première classe, c'est
probablement  l'un des ensembles les plus excitants
jamais mis en place
pour un film, je veux dire que les listes de
tous les jours sont assez
impressionnantes, mais je pense que la
chose vraiment excitante au-delà de cela, ce sont les nouveaux
personnages qui arrivent et les
acteurs qui font  que donc je ne lui ai vraiment
rien dit, sauf à quel point
c'était amusant  est et à quel point c'est époustouflant
de travailler avec tous ces acteurs et d'
être de retour avec le saumurage 12 ans depuis que
nous avons tous commencé une conversation est très
différent de quel bar devrions-nous aller
à la façon dont les enfants le font c'est très
différent